great idea tom film in front of
Parliament it'll be imposing it's
relevant the story it'll look great it
is covered in scattering when you buy a
tape measure that tape measure had to be
checked and calibrated with equipment at
the tape measure Factory and that
manufacturing equipment had to be
calibrated by other calibration
equipment that it's Factory and that
equipment had to be calibrated so on and
so on so and so until at some point that
chain has to stop there has to be an
organization whose job it is to say you
don't need to calibrate anymore
here is the truth these days that job's
done at the National Physical Laboratory
in the UK or the National Institute of
Standards and Technology in the u.s.
I've sure been lucky enough to visit
both of those in the past so I will put
links to those videos at the end of this
one the international standard for
length is the metre and it's based on
unchanging physical constants a metre is
defined as how far light travels in a
vacuum in a certain fraction of a second
is that all in frame I've got no idea I
can't see my screen but anyway ever
since the mid 20th century the
international agreement has been that an
inch is exactly twenty five point four
millimeters which means yes that in the
US and imperial systems of measurement
inches feet yards miles they're all
based on that trick now but before all
those modern standards were set those
systems of measurement were based on
prototypes not prototypes as in early
test versions but as in physical
artifacts which were by definition the
length they said they were the metre was
the distance between two marks on a
platinum iridium bar stored in Paris if
those marks somehow changed then the
definition of the metre changed with
them before we went metric Britain had
physical standards for the old imperial
units too dating back centuries there
were references to various standards all
through history but as far as I could
tell the first prototype that could
reasonably be called a British national
standard was a brass rod that was
created in 1760 that standard was
eventually set in law in 1825 the yard
so three feet 36 inches was defined as
being the distance between the marks on
that one object stored with the Clerk of
the House of Commons in parliament nine
years after that law was passed
Parliament burned down they were trying
to burn all records that were on wooden
tally sticks and the fire got out of
control that famous parliament building
the one that's behind the scaffolding it
isn't some ancient castle like the US
Capitol
is older than what's behind there only a
few parts from medieval times are
actually still standing the rest was
built during Queen Victoria's reign
after the fire anyway all the standards
for imperial units were also destroyed
in that fire the standard yard had been
partly melted which meant Britain didn't
have any legal standard of measurement
but that was fine because the law also
had a provision for what to do in that
case you make a new standard yard
defined by the length of a pendulum that
takes a certain amount of time to swing
great idea more the century early they
were defining the measurements by
physical constants just one problem
those definitions were wrong or as the
law later put it by the researchers of
scientific men doubts were thrown on the
accuracy those scientific men were the
standards Commission headed by
astronomer and mathematician Sir George
Harry that Commission was in charge of
Lee establishing the lost units and the
final report made it clear the
government had put a dodgy experiment
into law it wasn't accurate enough so
instead of the standard was
reconstructed based all the copies and
other versions had been made over whole
years all the objects not like tape
measures or anything like that but the
things that were one step down that
chain of calibration so by 1855 a new
physical yard had been constructed made
of runs and the law was changed to
define the idea of a yard as a distance
between two gold studs on that new bar
there were a few other suggestions in
the commission's report they strongly
argued for the decimalisation of units
and currency which wasn't successful for
a century but they also said that there
should be a public version of the
standards in every large town not
because they'd be perfectly accurate but
because it would make it really really
obvious if a shop keeper where the dodgy
tape measure was trying to cheat you
those standards still exist in a few
places in London you can find them in
Trafalgar Square in the guild hall and
by the gate of the Royal Observatory so
if you have bought lunch from let's say
a certain shop and you want to check if
your footlong sandwich really is a
footlong you can do that and I did so
was the new yard the same distance of
the old one well it would be difficult
to mess it up too much there are a lot
of copies of the original to work from
but every time you make an analogue copy
of something you do lose a little bit of
precision before the 1834 fire the yard
was the length
one particular block of metal after 1855
it was a length of another block in
between he could take a pretty accurate
guess but that chain of calibration that
source of truth was broken for 21 years
no one knew how long a yard a foot or an
inch actually was
you